- What would the hero of your life's
movie do right now, do that.
Unless you're kind and
friendly and warm and loving,
you're not going to enjoy
this life, you're just not.
Everyone encounters difficulties.
There is no easy road, it does not exist.
Oftentimes, people make the
mistake of getting stuck.
And it is just a tactical mistake.
- He's an American Comedian
and Sports Color Commentator.
As a fan of comedy, he started his stand
up career in 1988 in the Boston Area.
In 2009, he began his podcast
called The Joe Rogan Experience.
He's Joe Rogan and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way till the
end for some special bonus clips.
Also as Joe is talking,
if he says something
that really, really
resonates with you, please
leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it
as well so other people
can be inspired as well, enjoy.
(whooshing)
(basketball bounces)
(upbeat music)
(whooshing)
(intense music)
- Be the hero of your own movie.
If your life was a movie
and it started now,
forget about whatever
financial disasters you've had,
personal failures, relationship failures,
what would the hero of your life's movie
do right now, do that, do those things.
We define ourselves far too
often by our past failures.
We look at our past and
we say, well, that's me.
That's not you, you are
this person right now.
You're the person who's
learned from those failures
and you can choose to be
the hero of your own movie
right now, write down your goals.
Write down things you want to improve.
Write down things you won't
tolerate from yourself.
Write down things that
you've done in the past
that you never want to see
yourself do again and go forth
from here as the hero of your own movie.
Build momentum, build
confidence and momentum with
each good decision that
you make from here on out.
You can do it, anyone can do it.
We live in unique times, we
live in one of the rarest
times in human history where
you can choose almost all
of the input that comes your
way, whether its the movies
that you watch, the books you
read, the podcasts you listen
to, you can choose to be
inspired, do that, do that.
And be the hero of your own movie.
It's good to treat other
people the way you would
like to be treated yourself.
It's like a golden rule and
there's a reason for it.
And that reason is that
we're connected in some
strange way that we
don't totally understand.
And unless you are good to
other people around you,
unless you're a kind and
friendly and warm and loving,
you're not going to enjoy
this life, you're just not.
You're going to be
problems everywhere you go.
You're going to have
You got to figure out a
way to enjoy this life.
It's not because of Jesus,
it's not because of Moses.
It's not because of anybody
that may or may not have
ever existed, it's
because that's how you fit
in better in the world,
that's how you stay positive.
And it doesn't have to be
some that written 5,000 years
ago on animal skins, that
doesn't have to be the golden
rule because it's old, that's dumb.
We need to figure out
like now, today what is,
the best way to live your life, what is.
There's got to be ways
you could be putting forth
the most positive energy, I mean.
We know objectively
what's causing pollution.
We know objectively what's
causing birth defects
and we're taking in too much
chemicals and not enough
vitamins, we know
objectively all this stuff.
We know how to organize our
world and yet we don't do it.
We know how to organize our health
and yet very few people do
it, we know all these things.
The right path to being
a happy, healthy person
is to do all the that we already
know you're supposed to do.
Take care of your body,
take care of your health.
Take care of your mind,
your stress, meditate,
be kind to people, we all know that.
I mean, you ask anybody,
they know how to get by
and to be the most evolved
version of you that you can be.
It's not like a magical checklist.
If you talk to people
about it and you said,
okay, you got a person,
you want to improve them.
What are the things that
you're going to do to 'em?
Okay, well if I was a life
coach, the first thing I would
say is this guy's got to get
on a diet that makes him healthy.
I don't mean a diet just to lose weight.
I mean just healthy foods in your body,
many, many vegetables,
vegetables, a lot of good, good
quality protein, a lot
of water, stop the sodas,
stop the bull, start
workin' out your body.
And get a better sense
of like how this machine
feels when it's moving,
it's flowing better.
There's less tension in it,
your mind feels like relaxed
and you enjoy every single
moment of the day better.
Step one, everybody
knows that step, right?
What's step two, be cool to people.
Be nice to as many people as you can.
Smile at as many people as you can.
Have them smile back at
you, tip well when you go to
restaurants, just do the most you can.
Be as nice as you can and
just still manage to not
have people walk all over you.
Just get through this
life as nice as you can.
What else, do what you
want to do with your life.
Don't be doing something you don't enjoy.
Don't do something that's,
don't get locked into
a car that you can't afford
and doing something crazy
because you need the money, don't do that.
Do what you want to do, do
what the is it that you really
want to do, 'cause if someone
else is doin' it, you can do it.
Everybody makes their own
path through this world
but a lot of people don't
follow the path that
they really feel pulled to, ya know.
'Cause for whatever reason
they got negative programming.
When they were kids, someone
told 'em they couldn't do it
or told them to take the
shortcut or take the sure route.
That's a sad thing, man,
when you talk to dudes,
especially like talented
dudes and they don't follow up
with what they want to do, ya know.
There's a bunch of people
that will say, yeah,
well I have a family so
it's all great idea for you
to just go out there and go crazy.
I have people to support,
you need to listen.
Stop sayin' that, stop
sayin' any of those things.
Every single person who
has ever done anything
worthwhile or exceptional or
difficult or extraordinary,
anyone, whether it's
great artists or authors
or mathematicians or
whatever the it is, everyone
encounters difficulties,
there is no easy road.
It does not exist, it is
impossible, everyone has issues.
If you have time to pursue
a hobby, if you have time
to do anything in your life,
you can better yourself.
And here's one way you
never better yourself,
when you come up with
excuses for why other people
are successful and you're
not, that is dangerous.
When you give yourself an escape.
Well, that's easy for you to say, ya know
you do this or do do do do do, trust me.
Everybody has a hard
road, I wanted to jump out
a window several times
during my young life.
I wanted to jump in front
of a train, just end it
because it's just too
much pressure, not really.
But you know what I'm
sayin', theoretically.
We all go through hard times,
we all go through depression.
We all go through doubt and
moments in your life where
it's really difficult and
you're trying to figure
what the your path is
going to be, it's hard as.
But Steph and I, we were
talking about this before
the podcast starts that that
is what makes you a person.
And those difficult moments
are what build your character.
Show me a great man who's
the son of a great man.
That's what we were saying,
these kids that are born
billionaires, you're,
you're, you're never going
to be a self made person,
you have a back up trust
for your back up trust for
your trust, and you're man.
I'm fascinated by Marshall
Arts, I'm fascinated by comedy.
I'm fascinated by many,
many different things.
I don't understand when
people say they're bored.
Because if I had the
time to live 100 lives,
I'd be speaking different languages.
I'd be living in different countries.
I would try a number of different careers.
'Cause I think there's a lot
of unbelievable fascinating,
puzzling, complex things that
you could study in this world.
But that's just me and my
personality but that's the
personality also that I've cultivated
over the years of challenges.
- [Interviewer] Were you
like that as a kid too?
- Well, I was involved in
Marshall Arts very early.
And I think that is one of
the things that motivated
me to explore difficult tasks
because through difficult
tasks, you learn an incredible
amount about yourself.
And you, through the
fire of competition, you
get to understand, you get
to understand motivation.
You get to understand the
resistance that you have
inside your mind to doing hard work.
You get to understand the
rewards of discipline.
Like you don't truly appreciate
relaxation unless you've
worked hard and that is the
ying and the yang of life.
And I've said this to the
point of people getting sick
of it but one of the worst
decisions a man can make,
I can only speak for men,
obviously, is to be comfortable.
I don't think you should
try to be comfortable.
I think what you should try
to do is try to earn comfort.
And if you can get a day
off where you've worked hard
and you've accomplished goals,
that day off would be so sweet.
When I work hard and I
sit in front of the TV,
I enjoy the out of it, I put my feet up.
I have a nice drink, I enjoy my free time.
- [Interviewer] Get one of those chairs
that kneads your back
or something like that.
- I do have one of those.
- Do you really?
- Those are great.
- They're great, right?
- I don't use it that
much though, honestly.
I'm more of a workaholic
than I should be, probably.
If the balance was, I probably
should relax more than I do.
But I never feel like I earned it.
But that's part of the reason
whey when I do feel like
I earned it, I can enjoy it.
It's 'cause I am more connected
to the idea that I need
to accomplish things and it's
not like for anybody else's
benefit other than my own
or anybody else's approval
other than my own, I
just, when I have a task,
whether it's, like today I'm
going to write 1,000 words
or 2,000 or whatever the number is.
If I don't do that, I'm
not, I write things down.
Like I'll write down a
list of things to get
accomplished that day and
if I don't accomplish that,
I'll get sick, like it'll drive me crazy.
If I can't fill out that
list, that drives me nuts.
But that's what led me to
be a championship level
Marshall Artist, that's
what led me to achieve the,
it's like that, it's the
reinforcement of those goals.
Like understanding that you
can achieve those goals.
It's going to be difficult,
you're going to push through
the difficulty and then you're
going to understand what
difficulty truly is and how
much of it is just mental,
how much of it is just in your mind.
This adversity to difficult
task or to struggle
and a lot of people have
that, they're scared.
They're scared of complications,
they're scared of failure.
Failure's a big one that
people are afraid of
but failure is one of the
most important things you
could ever have as far as like
the motivation to do things differently.
One of the reasons why I think
that I'm good at friendships
and relationships is because
I've failed at them in the past.
One of things that I'm good at, comedy,
is because I bombed on stage.
One of the reasons why I'm
good at work is because
I've been a worker in the
past and I know the feeling
of failure, the feeling of
shame of being like a weak
non motivated, lazy person,
it's a weak feeling.
You don't respect yourself
and I have this phrase
that I use all the time to
people to try to motivate
people, I say that, be the
hero in your own movie.
Pretend that if your life
was a movie and your life
started now, what would the hero do?
What would the person that you respect do?
What would the person that you admire,
the person that inspires
you, what would they do.
Well, do that and if you
do that, you slowly build
momentum, you like, today
I did what I wanted to do.
Today I started a class
in Yoga, I did this.
I did all these things I was
saying I wasn't going to do.
And now I feel momentum and
momentum is a very important
point in people's lives,
that's why some folks don't
like to take days off because
they feel like they're
losing momentum and they
sort of have to restart the
wheel up again after a vacation.
And there's a lot of folks that live life
on a cushy cloud of marshmallows and bull
and then one day something
goes wrong and I mean,
that's why spoiled kids are so sad.
Like a spoiled young boy is
one of the saddest things ever.
A young boy that becomes a
man and can't take care of
himself and his dad has
to keep on rescuing him.
His dad has to keep on
bailing him out of situations
and giving him money,
I've met guys like that.
And that is a crippling
affliction when they don't have
the character themselves to
be able to get by in life.
They constantly need someone
to help them and bail them out.
Even as a grown man, I've
met guys in their 40s that
still need help from their parents.
I'm like what the, man, you're
never going to get it right.
Because somewhere along
the line they didn't face
enough of the adversity
to realize that there's
sometimes you just got
to get up and get done.
That sometimes we have to pull yourself up
and you have to push forward
even if you want to stay in bed.
And if you don't do and you
just calling on your daddy
and your daddy keeps rescuing you,
you never develop those tools.
You never develop that
ability to recognize what
you're doing wrong with your
life 'cause you're soft.
You got it cushiony, you got a safety net,
a safety net for your safety net.
If you had a kid, obviously
you do have a kid.
But say if you had like a 20 year old
and he's just a doper
where he wake and bakes
and doesn't get anything
done, he's just always like
hangin' out with his friends
and playing video games
and he's just a loser, I
wish there was a way you
could show someone like
that, like I know that you're
getting some comfort and
satisfaction out of just
laying around, doin'
nothing, eating, getting fat.
But your life would feel
better and richer if you
had a goal, you chased that
goal, you accomplished some
things, you would get
this boost of confidence.
You would get this boost of self esteem.
Like whatever it is
that you're into doin'.
Maybe you're into drawing comic books.
Maybe you're into making
pottery or sculptures
or, but find whatever the
that is and pursue that
instead of doing nothing,
like the people that
are doing nothing, those
are the real people.
Look, doing something
might be as simple as that
Alex Honnold guy, he just climbs rocks.
But he's world class rock climber.
- It's something, though.
- It's something.
- And it's also a goal of his
and he's also the best at it, right.
But those people who smoke pot all day.
Those are also the guys
who hate on Joe Rogan
for being in shape, you
know what I'm saying
or being disciplined or get
on Kevin Hart's Instagram
and hate on, you know what I'm saying?
Because they don't, it's
their own insecurities.
I see what you're saying
but I would assume they
would get motivated by seeing
other people do something
with their lives, like
that should be motivating
not discouraging.
- Yeah.
But if you grew up with losers
and you're around a bunch
of people with attitudes,
especially if it's in your
household, I was very lucky
that both my mom and my stepdad,
they're not, they are the
least hater people I've
ever met in my life, they are
just not haters in any way.
Like if someone's doing
well, they're always like,
wow, look at this guy
or like wow, look at her
or wow, look at him, there was
never any hate in my house.
In terms of other people's
success but if you grew
up with a dad and your
dad's like, yeah, these,
all these assholes, this
thinks she's a bad ass.
And there's people that look
at other people's success
and instead of saying, wow,
that guy did a lot of work.
The way, I'm a successful
person but the way I look
at Kevin Hart, he exhausts me, ya know.
Or The Rock, those guys exhaust me.
I'm like Jesus Christ, I
feel lazy next to those guys.
They do so much, like those
guys are so overbearingly
ambitious but some people, they see that
and they compare themselves
and they don't like it
so they start getting really
and it's like a natural
feeling to try to chip
away at that person.
And the worst people that
you know are the people
that don't have a good
self judge, that everything
they do is awesome, those
never grow anywhere.
And that's a huge issue with comedy.
When you run into people who
have terrible comedy sets
but think they did great.
We would always, Greg
Fitzsimmons and I would always
talk about that with like open mic-ers.
Like there's people that
hear phantom laughs.
Like they think they're
doin' great and they have
this delusional self opinion
where everything they
do is awesome and they don't know why
they're not successful already.
They don't know why they're not famous.
And those people, I
believe, I mean, in some
sort of a weird, narcissist
way, you could look at this way,
that those people are there to teach you.
This is the consequences
of not feeling that
awful feeling when you fail.
I was talkin' to Burr a couple weeks ago.
He did a set at The Comedy
Store and I saw part of it.
He was killin' and then I
ran into him in the hallway
and I go, ah man, main
room show was great, right?
And he goes, yeah, I up the end though.
I tried to hang in there too
long and the last bit bombed.
Like he was just, it was rottin'
at him that the last bit,
he goes, I hung in there too long.
I should've got off of
that bit before that.
But ya know, when I was
in there he was killing.
But that wasn't in his mind,
the success was not in his mind.
It was like okay, whatever
that happened at the
end, don't do that again, ya know.
But that's why he's Bill Burr.
That's why he's really good.
When you're alone with your thoughts,
you get an idea of what
your thoughts actually are.
If you live your life
just acting constantly on
the momentum of other
people's expectations,
of you wanting to be liked
by these other people,
you can run into a trap
and you set up a life
that you didn't really want, you're.
You're trapped in this
situation where you have
a mortgage, you have credit card bills.
You got student loans you have to pay.
You have a bunch of going
on that you have to continue
to feed and all that, and
especially if you have a family.
And you have to feed them, oh my goodness.
Then you're fully locked in,
you can't take any chances
whatsoever and often times,
people make the mistake
of getting stuck and it
is just a tactical mistake
just like it would be a
mistake if you got stuck
in a video game, just
like it would be a mistake
if you followed a map incorrectly
and you got stuck in the woods.
Your life is certainly
some sort of a journey.
It's certainly some sort
of journey and we have to
all be aware that when
we're making journeys,
we're not going to always
make the right steps.
And sometimes you have
to back up and try again
and if you're in a position
where you can't back up
and try again, you've trapped yourself.
And the system will set
out honey pots for people
to get trapped in, the
system will set out ideas
of retirement, the ideas
of the golden years,
providing you benefits, providing
you a healthy work environment, why?
Well, because they want
people to work for them.
They don't want people to
realize their own dreams
and escape and that's a pain
in the ass so you got to
hire more people and train them.
They want to set it up
so that you stick around.
Stick around in some sort
of an unsatisfying world.
It's up to you to see
that video game problem,
to see that issue as
it comes up on the map.
And no, I think this is a right turn.
To see all the problems that
could potentially lay in
front of you and calculate your future.
And also look around all
the people that didn't do it
and look at the misery that they're in
and learn that you don't
want to be like them.
And then look at the people
that have kind of taken
chances and navigated their way.
What did they do differently than you?
What objectivity do they
have that maybe you lack?
What insight into their own
mistakes are they willing
to delve into that you're
not, that you step back
and go, I just don't want to
look at myself that closely?
But the person who's able
to look at themselves the
closest is going to get
the more rational results.
One of the things that's
causing this funk that people
are in is that we're living
our lives, many of us at least
in these very unfulfilling
ways where you're going to
this office with artificial light
and you're doing something you
don't want to do all day long
and then you get home and you're tired.
And on top of that, you're
eating, you're eating
potato chips and you're drinking soda.
And your body is just
like what in the is this?
We're supposed to be out in the fields.
We're supposed to be walking up hills.
We're supposed to be looking for animals
or gathering vegetables,
we're supposed to be doing all
these things that our
body's designed to do.
We're supposed to be in
nature and nature is like a
medicine, like it literally
is a medicine to you.
Like people that go, you
don't have to go hunting.
You don't have to go
fishing, just go hike man.
Just go hike up to the top of a mountain
and look out, ya know,
there's a reward that you get
from that is intensely like soul filling.
There's like something
about, when I was in Colorado
and there was this area of
Boulder where you drive up
one of these roads and there
was this area where you
could park and it was
this incredible view, man.
And these people just
park and just go out there
and just look but you get
there and you park and you
go, 'cause you would see,
you're literally seeing
the Continental Divide,
these snow capped mountains
in July, in July it's covered in snow
'cause those mountains don't give a.
One thing that we are, we're an animal.
But we're also the next
stage of animals where
we're aware of who we are
and we contemplate our
existence and when you
contemplate your existence
and you're an intelligent
life form, you should
always be seeking to improve.
If you're always seeking
to improve, the thing that
you look at, like what has
brought me the most positive results?
So it's kindness, it's
kindness, it's friendship.
The connection with human
beings on a very positive
level where you like build up like a trust
and you have warmth and
friendship and you route
for each other and you
share in each other's bounty
and you build together,
that, we all know inherently
in our heads that kindness
is like one of the best
gifts you can bestow another
human being whether it's
giving them food and they
don't have any or helping
them out or hooking them up or
doing something to help 'em,
just, or being around them
and complimenting them,
whatever the it is, we know
that inherently that feels great.
We know it, we know that that's the next,
we have to figure out how to
use our resources together
so that we can be like that all the time.
I think it's always about
doin' what you actually
want to be doin' with
your life as far as if you
have an inner creative
expression to get out.
There's a lot of people who
just always wanted to be
singers and they just for
whatever reason, never pursued it.
So they just sing around
their house and they always
wonder what could've been
if they just tried to
be a singer, that's one form
of, that could bum you out.
That's one form of a
road block in your life,
the depressed feeling that you didn't try,
that you didn't try to
reach your potential.
You didn't go after what
is intriguing to you.
We all have almost like
a beacon that pulls us
in a certain direction, for
some people it's nursing.
For some people it's
construction and architecture.
- [Man] Being a parent for some people.
- [Joe] Yeah, for some,
for us it was stand up.
It was really simple
and there's something,
the happiness that's involved
in pursuing your inherent
desires is unavoidable, I mean, it's not,
it's unappreciated,
it's under appreciated.
People think well all you
have to do find a career.
Yes, all you have to do is find a career.
But I guarantee you
there's one out there that
you really, really want to do.
- Yeah the key is.
- Unless it's just
like, I want to be famous,
then you're an asshole.
- [Man] Well, that's
what I was going to say.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Cee SayDee asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what
did Joe say that had the
biggest impact on you, what
change are you going to
make in your life or business
after watching this video.
Please leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Tuan Nguyen,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really,
really, really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever Your One Word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(ball bounces)
- [Joe] The idea that
we live literally on a
gigantic organic space
ship, ya know, that's
just too up, it's too crazy to think.
It's so much easier to
think about Tiger Woods
and what was Jesse James
thinking and it's so much
easier to distract yourself
with who wears this dress
better in US Magazine, 76% say this girl.
It's, I think as human beings,
we have, we're in a weird
sort of an adolescent stage of evolution
and we have these incredible,
technical and technological
capabilities and this insane
ability to communicate
with people all over the
world and this insane
ability to exchange
information but we're still
trapped in this monkey body
and we still have these
monkey instincts and we
work like incredible hours.
And if you see kids in
school now, they have insane
amounts of homework,
they're training you to
be a God damn drone, I mean,
you work all day in school.
And then you come home and
you have hours and hours
of homework, three and four
hours of homework a night
to the point where you're
just accustomed to like
doing things you don't want
to do and then you're going to
take that and you're
going to go to college.
You're going to work on
it there and eventually
you're going to get a job
and that job is going to
require hours and hours
of your day to the point
where you don't have time
to thing about space.
You don't have time to
think about is there some
sort of a weird connection
between every human
being on the planet and every
single action that you do.
Is life itself really
some sort of a gigantic
mathematical equation, it's too bizarre
and unrecognizable to the average person.
But those thoughts,
there's no room for those
when you have to get up
for work in five hours
and your baby's crying
and you got to get gas.
And there's all sort of
issues that people have
that keep them from
thinking about the real
weird aspects of this life,
this life is incredibly bizarre.
JBS Haldane said it best,
not only is the world
stranger than you suppose, it's
stranger than you can
suppose, it really is.
When you start getting into
like, you start getting
into Quantum Physics and
the idea of particles
and super divisions where
they can exist in motion
and be still at the same
time and then there's
subatomic particles that
link in and out of existence
and they exist in two different
places at the same time,
what the is going on?
(laughing)
Ya know, it's too much, it's too crazy.
In order for you to take
care of your mortgage,
in order for you to be a
good neighbor and chill
for the Homeowner's Association
meeting on Tuesday night
and gossip with the
neighbors about who's losin'
their house, there's too many variables.
There's too much things
going on that people
gravitate towards stupid
meaningless because it's
easy to absorb and because
it jives well with our
monkey instincts, the Large
Hadron Collider doesn't
nearly as much weight in the news.
There's a bunch of,
there's 10,000 scientists
that are making black holes.
That's not getting the news,
that's not getting
nearly as much attention.
We're so strange that we're like a movie.
We, the whole human
race is like a God damn
Coen Brothers Movie,
there's a certain amount of
programming that the media does especially
if you watch stuff like Fox News.
There's a certain amount
where they're sort of
conditioning people to
think a certain way.
But for the most part, it's
what people are interested in.
I think, the really deep
scary stuff is too daunting
for a lot of people, there's
something about people that
it's like, they don't want to
know what's behind the door.
They don't want to know what's outside.
It's too scary, they want to
control their micro world.
And they, that's why people
like having a small group
of friends and living in a small community
and they like to know their environment.
And when you get into really
crazy like Quantum Physics
and you get into the
universe and infinity,
the idea of an infinite
universe and perhaps
not even just one universe
but infinite numbers of
universes, it's just too nuts.
It's too crazy to think that above you
literally goes on
forever, there is no roof.
You step outside your
house and there is no,
you can make a straight
line from your head
to a star that's 14
billion light years away.
That's insane, that's one
of the things that hits
you when you do mushrooms,
especially if you do
a large dose, you start
realizing that there's no
ground, there's no up and no down.
You're like in the middle of
this and there's no edges.
It just goes, it goes
forever and you're like,
you're just like right
there, you're right there
swimming in this universal soup.
(pleasant music)